ihr weg führte nec bruder mit 18 nach
deutschland wo sie anthropologie
studiert und ihre musikkarriere startete
doch die sorge um ihre heimat nigeria
ließ sie nie ruhen
um etwas zu erreichen musste ich nach
nigeria zurück und dort mit anpacken
wandel von dem ich singe und nicht sehen
möchte
ihr kampf gilt der korruption und der
ausbeutung der nigerianischen
ölvorkommen durch internationale multis
am wochenende wird in nigeria gewählt
doch neckar fehlt der glaube dass sich
dadurch etwas ändern in der geschichte
nigerias gibt es nur korrupte politiker
alles was wir tun können ist dies
anzuprangern
so nutzt die sängerin ihre weltweite
bekanntheit um auf die großen probleme
im land aufmerksam zu machen
sie engagiert sich mit dem humanitären
projekte
damit will es jugendliche ermutigen mit
musik oder mode eine perspektive abseits
der gewalt zu suchen
heute vielleicht wichtiger denn je seit
mit boko haram die vielleicht schlimmste
solche im land wütet auch darüber singt
neckar es ist ihre eigene verzweiflung
ihr schmerz der sie dazu antreibt wenn
du so viel blutvergießen siehst so viele
unschuldige menschen die sterben
da fing dann fühlst du entweder hass
oder aus hass entstand betraut
dabei wären friede und vergebung der
einzige weg neckar stellt sich damit in
die tradition eines bob marley
wenn ich mich in jemanden hinein
versetzte der seine geliebte menschen
verloren hat
dann versuche ich nicht in hass zu
verfallen sondern über mich in vergebung
so verrückt das klingen mag
du kämpfst im namen der religion
ich will dir zeigen wie man betet ich
bringe dich zu einer moschee und zeige
dir das blutvergießen nicht zum beten
gehört kämpfst du im namen von christus
bringe ich dich zur kirche und zeigen
dir wie du beten sonst was immer du
glaubst ich zeige dir das gott nichts
mit blutvergießen zu tun hat soweit ich
das tut mir leid aber das geht mir sehr
nahe doch ihre botschaft wollen nicht
alle hören
manche nigerianer sehen in ihr eine
nestbeschmutzerin weil sie ihre kritik
offen äußert allerdings ohne politische
absichten
ich wäre keine gute politikerin weil ich
viel zu emotional reagieren würde
ich singe lieber davon hier und da wie
ein schmetterling tanz mit dem teufel
und hoffe etwas davon
m